Ubisoft closed out their press  conference by revealing steep and open  world action sports game partially set  in the Alps the game is being created by  the division contributing developer  Ubisoft annecy Steve includes sports  like skiing paragliding snowboarding and  traversal in a wingsuit there are  challenges to take on and the option to  share your runs online if you like all  players will zip down the same mountain  and can interact with each other  although you also appear to be able to  disable collision to keep from smashing  into other players Ubisoft revealed that  steep will let players choose between  first and third person while there will  also be a free cam option as well as a  GoPro like perspective for all the  latest on this one and everything else  that's been happening at e3 today check  back to gamespot